[Music]
hey man good to see you again you did a
phenomenal job in this film in fact one
of my favorite parts of the whole movie
was Chewbacca I mean big deal
congratulations thank you so much was it
like for you watching yourself in the
Chewbacca suit well I was trying to
watch how I well I did but the story
just sucked me in and it became what I
expected this great adventure story
that's fun and full of twists and turns
and it was just so much and I'm so happy
that Chewbacca elicited some laughs yeah
a lot of laughs and he really kind of is
a big sting scene stealer yeah sure now
but you mentioned to me that I was going
to enjoy a sigh on the red carpet and
then after seeing the film the
relationship between han and chewbacca
Brown and Chewie that we've known it was
incredible to see the origins of that I
mean how much pressure did you feel kind
of having to be a part of that and set
all of that up everything that we know
about those two yeah it was a lot it was
a lot because we needed to make it make
it come out with a bang and going into
filming we talked with Alden we talked
how to best approach this how to her
each scene what to do
so that it becomes this are they gonna
become friends or is it gonna end
off fully and that was a real thing that
we tried to convey 190 years old huh
exactly yes pretty good he's been around
ya know a lot of people wouldn't realize
that playing Chewbacca you know they
just think you've got to kind of go
through the physical aspect but you have
to learn lines I mean you have to like
listen and react him exactly and do them
do the voice I mean how did you like
work on that did you have to do that in
the audition what works out for me and
no it'sit's it's acting up and I have
less tools I I'm in a mask yeah I'm
trying to tell a story with my body and
it's reacting to the other actors and
and playing this character that is very
unique moves in a very specific way
and then you have to be just be in the
moment and that's what it's all about
Alvin said that he he tried to learn a
little Wookiee mm-hmm how do you do oh
yeah I went into his trailer and he said
do that Wookiee thing for me and then I
started doing it I whips out a camera
starts filming me you see what you do
wanted to learn yeah he was so cuz he
prepared for everything he was making
notes and he was so studious that I can
believe
how well-prepared he came and and as we
could see he just rocked it well you did
a great job acting there's a few other
variables in the equation in order to
book this role and one of them being
that he had to be a large a large man
seven feet tall you are and in fact I
made your Instagram he posted the
picture of me standing on the Left I
mean I'm not a small guy I'm six foot
two and but yeah thanks for posting that
I felt kind of excited no problem when
you were at the audition where there's
just a bunch of like seven footers
around how was it
know that we came in that was one that I
saw okay okay and he actually he became
a wookie for for this movie as well so
they got his contacts and I I can't
remember his name right now but yeah but
um but yeah it's a wonderful this this
audition process because I was pretty I
was pretty confident because how many
you 7-footers with blue eyes you have in
the world but still I was having
sleepless nights what if I don't get it
what if something happens and it was for
five months but I was I was feeling
pretty good and yeah eventually that
call came between the audition and you
actually getting the call that you
booked it was five months did you say
something like that's not even right I
mean that's not that's you must have
been going through torture yeah exactly
it was just waiting and being being
waiting for okay's from the studios and
everything and it was a lot of like I
didn't know that then but it was a lot
of good wheels turning we're used to
seeing in August a han Solo and Chewie
hanging out together han Solo in the
form of Harrison Ford for so many years
did you get a chance to meet Harris
on set I know what you did oh yeah yes I
mean he's just a little urchin that
everyone knows when he came all said
everyone used to quiet down and and
until Harrison cracks a joke or
something and it was very when he came
on it's intense because he carries this
weight and charisma for sure does
similar to all done now I mean he build
as we progressed this this movie he
became this character that we all know
and love how Han Solo and as and this
this this movie really chose tells the
story about young Han and young Chui and
in the beginning they're still searching
and they're not yet what they are one
day gonna be and that was exciting about
making this film that's amazing dude
dude Harrison give you any insights into
the Chewie that he knows any advice
person as you may know Harrison doesn't
really pay attention to to the Wookiees
and they're know Harrison loved that
Harrison loved because we me and Peter
Coe worked and Chewbacca suit and force
awakens right Harrison was just I think
he was happy to be Han Solo and I
wouldn't presume to go no more than that
okay okay I'm sorry about Peter filling
Peters shoes literally that's a big deal
and you know how was that for you and
how much advice or insights did Peter
kind of offer to you I mean so much he
told me he's reasoning behind in those
in that wookie boot camp he told me what
why he did our certain thing why he
would look in an angle like that and and
it was so because I had done lots of
study in my own own time before that it
was so good to finally hear from the
from the man himself why he did a
certain way and it helped me
tremendously to prayer prayer for
example for this film I really mean this
it was seamless
you know you who as viewers we would
never we would never have known it was
it was pretty impressive nation now
obviously a French lives like this has
really serious non-disclosure agreements
there's a lot of secrecy kind of going
into this Aldens
kind of spilled the beans of his
involvement with even though he had an
NDA but you had guests onset did
anything like that happen you know with
the secrecy leaking out a little bit no
I can be really believable when I tell
them listen don't tell anything but
nobody you spilled anything is very good
and also I have the added benefit of
being a sort of anonymous inside the
suit which I love and and it means that
the test for me doing my job well is
that people still think it's Peter
Mayhew in the suit and but but I also
love to be recognized nowadays because
the movies coming out and Chewbacca is
in it loads so so it's it's it's great
Oh everything's great you kind of stand
out in a crowd you suit but guess what
we know which guy out of the group was
playing to Baca
exactly right all right real quick I
don't have much more time but fan
encounters it's out there now people I
mean obviously you this isn't your first
time playing Baca but like what are your
most memorable or craziest fan
encounters for being part of this
incredible friendship exactly I think
it's the smallest of the small kids who
love Chewbacca and when they hear me
doing the voice
they just their eyes light up and and
they want one meter for pictures I
usually pick them up and it's it's just
a wonderful world because the fans are
are they've been there since day one and
they're the best and who carry the torch
forward for us you're awesome man thank
you great great to see you
congratulations you really did do a
great job the relationship between han
and chewie was I think probably by one
of my favorite parts of the entire film
just that connect connection
[Music]